good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm
making this video at a time distant for
many of my books or movie adaptations
stuff coming out so that it doesn't
appear to be about me which I really
hope it isn't but of course I'm
inevitably warped by my own experience
more on how I might be wrong later
actually ok so I started out my writing
career as a book reviewer between 2000
and 2005 I reviewed hundreds of books
for Booklist magazine
I reviewed young adult novels and
picture books and romance novels and
books about boxing and books about early
Islamic history and books about
conjoined twins the number of books
about conjoined twins by the way is
truly astonishing also I've been lucky
enough to review some great books for
the New York Times Book Review including
Eleanor & Park and The Book Thief and
The Hunger Games
this all happened back at the beginning
of the age of everyone reviewing
everything a wave that I have ridden
profitably if at times uncomfortably my
entire adult life in fact my ongoing
fascination with the format and the
ubiquity of the review led me to my
podcast the anthropocene reviewed I was
like if people can review their haircuts
and their breakfasts why not cholera or
the strange human habit of whispering so
to be clear I am strongly in favor of
reviewing I think thoughtful analysis of
art is vital to the creation of good art
and I think it can be super helpful to
look at art through a lens like looking
at Game of Thrones through the lens of
climate change for instance or looking
at Jane Eyre through the lens of
shifting gender norms but I tend to be
less moved by criticism in the
colloquial sense of the word like
articles or videos explaining everything
wrong with X or 14 reasons Z is terrible
or whatever now of course it's important
to point out flaws in art that can help
encourage the creation of better art but
I think the most important thing
criticism can do is find and lift up
important and beautiful work that might
otherwise go unnoticed I don't read to
discover what's wrong with a story
although there are many something's
wrong with every story I read to be
moved in every sense of the word to go
to places I haven't been and to glimpse
worlds I otherwise couldn't see
including the world's deep within myself
and critics whether in the New York
Times are on Goodreads can help us to
discover the books that will move us and
also give us a framework through which
to think about them so I think what we
mean when we say a book is quote-unquote
good is that it's worth our attention a
good book is one that if read Jenner
we'll offer big gifts in return and part
of what frustrates me about the
everything wrong with X school of
criticism is that it mostly makes the
case for not paying attention to
something which i think is a case
usually best made by not paying
attention to something of course there
are exceptions when really popular work
is culturally destructive for instance
but I just don't think that in general
communities organized around hating art
that deserves less attention are as
productive as communities organized
around loving art that deserves more
attention so that's how I try to read in
critique with an eye toward what about
this experience is valuable and worthy
of attention what stories have expanded
my universe or changed the way I think
among recent reads Melinda Gates is the
moment of lift has changed the way I
think about gender discrimination and
its role in poverty and the graphic
novel adaptation of kindred has kept me
thinking about the past's omnipresence
both those books felt like really good
investments of my attention which is how
I'm trying to think about reading these
days I'm trying to think less about
whether something is good or bad and
more about which works of art I should
look at and how to look at them of
course I might be wrong about how to
read in review I do remember a time when
the ideals that animated my life felt
certain and important and I was
absolutely sure that I was contributing
to culture in a positive way but that
moment has passed and now I am uncertain
about everything I'm even uncertain
about being uncertain should I have
unshakeable police maybe but for now I'm
letting books and art and life shake
them Hank I'll see you on Friday